ist halt an was du dich jemals gefragt
was seine haustiere so denken
ich vermisse sie ich vermisse sie wie
verrückt wir haben gerade petz gesehen
patch ist neuer animationsfilm von den
machern von den minions worüber sie
reden was sie machen wenn du nicht zu
hause bist eigentlich um zwei tiere zwei
hunde die sich ja die zueinander finden
auf merkwürdigerweise und dann sehe ich
immer mehr anfreunden und von zu hause
weg verlieren
und ja dann zurückkommen müssen du bist
der neue fund und hate you warum machst
du denn schon war es mich an fallen mir
das gesicht beißen prima warte nun ist
sie davon erfährt dass du zurück bist
ich habe versucht sie zu stoppen
dabei hilft es gibt tatsächlich
wahnsinnig viele verschiedene tiere die
alle ganz stark ausgearbeitete
charaktere haben wieder sehen ich fand
ja geht am besten bietet ist ein
schoßhündchen eigentlich ein weißes
flauschiges niedliches schoßhündchen
aber als dann ihr freund verschwindet in
dem sie heimlich sehr verliebt ist dann
dreht sie plötzlich unglaublich auf und
sind ein ganz heldenhaftes fähnchen für
mich der bösewicht ein hase der total
entsetzt von der menschheit ist und den
untergang der menschheit plan dass wir
ignoriert ihr bitte tatsächlich ein
bisschen wie bei pinky und brain dass
die verstoßenen haustiere die
weltherrschaft anstreben
wir sind die weggeworfene haustiere von
uns und wissen verstoßen und jetzt aber
auch ähnlich schlechte pläne haben die
pinky und brain früher immer es klappt
nicht so richtig meine
18 genau aufgezeichnet alles darüber
clusters runde schraube locker
der film hat jetzt nicht so einen
unglaublichen tiefgang wie zum beispiel
so wenn ja wo man sagen könnte es geht
um unsere gesamte gesellschaft und es
möchte uns sagen dass wir eigentlich
alle friedlich koexistieren können oder
so so ist es nicht
es ist einfach wirklich ein sehr
lustiger film ein wahnsinnig toll
gemacht erfüllen mit ganz großartigen
actionreichen szenen trotzdem gut aus
das ist auch ein super film für familien
weil die kinder wirklich viel zu lachen
haben und die erwachsenen auf wahnsinnig
sie zu gucken weil sie sehen ja das war
so da gab es wirklich ein paar relativ
harte szenen und für kleine kinder hätte
ich das jetzt nicht geeignet gehalten
aber jetzt dieser film der ist wirklich
total okay sei ein braver junge leona